I like it it looks good I read like
everybody welcome to another Google
hangout super excited to be back on with
you today we're talking about how to
market your business you can land new
clients and I have a special guest with
me Patrick from Aweber Aweber is the
email marketing software that I've been
using for the past 10 plus years in my
business and Patrick's on board to help
answer your questions on how to market
your business Patrick welcome aboard
yeah appreciate it thanks a lot of in
for having me definitely excited to you
know to provide some value here to your
audience and kind of go through use
cases of you know business owners and
entrepreneurs it's it's certainly right
up our alley in terms of where a whoever
came from and how we grew so and
currently you know what we're providing
today so awesome to be here thanks for
having me I love the matching
backgrounds I got the believe back here
you got the a Ripper in the background
it's good have you got the basketball to
play tonight there's not my personal
name but it's so this hold and this is
good enough so we're talking about
marketing today and in marketing I'm a
huge believer in you know you can use
sales and marketing to very business but
I'm not the sales guy you know if my
business relied on me doing cold calling
my business would fail it's all about
marketing for me and it's about critten
engine where people want to come and
find me and they're searching for me and
then when you have a call with them
they're already kind of pre-sold on what
you're all about is way easier to land
the deal there's a bunch of questions
coming in but before getting to those do
you have any kind of high-level tips or
reviews or philosophy on marketing that
might help the entrepreneur abeyance
yeah so you know you kind of started
speaking to creating this this warm you
know funnel right so we talked about
sales funnels and you know certainly
kind of ties into a lot of what we do
here at Aweber creating educate
educational content not always just
talking about what service or product
you provide right so kind of creating
that conversation between two you know
business entities before you actually
jump into working with each other so a
lot of what I do here at Aweber is work
with a lot of the cross monk
teams on creating various types of
different content that really provides
value to your network or someone else's
network so in the case of you know email
marketing with Aweber anyone else
it's it's it's really important and most
important to kind of become that thought
leader and whatever you do whatever
product or service you provide so a lot
of what we do you know we you know we're
the authority in email marketing is kind
of work to produce a lot of that content
and that creates that inbound funnel and
those warm conversations as you alluded
to which are most important I've done a
ton of cold calling in my day and you
know you have to kind of keep it in the
grind to kind of reach out to new to new
prospects and new companies but really
at the heart of it is you know providing
valuable content to your network and and
creating that that warm those warm
conversations so they already kind of
want to work with you you know before
you even meet yeah I love I think
email marketing also plays a role into
it not just because we're talking to
guys from Aweber but because it's really
helped my business I mean for those of
you watching live most of you came
probably from my email list and I think
a big mistake that entrepreneurs make is
they they might start creating the
content but then they don't have a
funnel to catch them and it's very few
people who will come to your website or
watch one YouTube video that you create
and then by you know they want to you
have to date before you get married and
so oh I see email marketing to do that
where if you have a free guide you have
something valuable in your newsletter it
gives permission to connect with people
on an ongoing basis and if you continue
to share your authority in your emails
not just by now you know this is a great
product you need to let's get married
right now exactly right
you keep providing the content using
autoresponders then people know you like
you trust you and with time then they'll
they'll buy they'll be loyal customers
and there were people on to you as well
yeah we have you know speaking to a lot
of the testimonials and our current
clients that we work with I mean that's
exactly what they do so they're not
going right for the sell you know if
they whether they have a product or
service right out of the gate they're
kind of they're building their email
lists they're building them in their
influence
with content so we talked about
autoresponders and you know people out
there you guys may have some drip
campaigns or automation you might be
setting up which is very important so
outside of those daily weekly monthly
emails you send you want to kind of
create this this nurture track where
they're really kind of being provided
various types of content depending upon
where they are in you know the
educational cycle you know whether
they're ready ready to buy or not and
you might put others that are might be
kind of on the fence ready to jump in in
a different type of autoresponder or
funnel cool well let's get into the
questions and for those you're watching
live there's a little question box on
the right hand side you can put your
questions in there and I'll try to flag
them and bring them up as they come up
the first one came in from Jay Rhys
who's a loyal viewer and fan of the show
who was talking about marketing to a
very elite select group so not mass
marketing strategies but he only wants
to work with the certain select few
people in his running how can I reach
out and connect with those guys yeah so
that that's huge I mean we you know at
kind of in the Aweber in the email
marketing world our clients are not just
kind of you know blasting out
communications on kind of like you know
thrown paint against the wall so they
they're always looking for ways to get
more targeted so we talked about
segmentation kind of targeting those
people who are really interested maybe
more so than you know just a larger list
and a larger scope you may be reaching
out to so I would say it his business
case whatever that is if there's a
select known group of people that that
he can target that somewhere along the
line has kind of raised their hand and
said we're interested in you and your
product or service we want to hear more
you know the email side of things you
know the autoresponders the automation
to kind of really reach out to those
guys and then also just asking asking
for feedback if he has an idea of a
select group of people that he thinks
would be good for him we'll try to get a
better judge you know as far as what
their feedback is you know cuz you know
he might be not a hundred percent right
but just you know kind of a lot of
we do here internally however is just
asking for feedback and getting a sense
from that community really what they
want before any kind of actions taken
and you know without just assuming right
out of the gate sure now I know a little
bit more Golgi arises business because
he's been such a loyal fan but in
general as it stands for this kind of
question
I've been looking at one what kind of
referrals I might be able to build in so
who else is selling to these elite
people and how can you make contact with
them to potentially have them introduce
you to those clients so it's not all on
you doing the heavy lifting and maybe
you could introduce you know your
clients to that referral partner as well
it's a lot easier to sell through
partners and to try to sell one at a
time one at a time at a time and two if
you have a sense of if you can really
target and know who that person is I'd
look into Facebook advertising - if you
know that the people you're going after
from Philly and love March Madness and
you know fans of the from the
Philadelphia Phillies and you know
listen to Justin Bieber you know that's
that's like your target customer and a
little beaver once in a while I got to
throw in some Canadian content there you
know you can find those people on on
Facebook you can advertise just to those
people and then you can send them to a
landing page and you can have an email
campaign attached to that landing page
so if you know the kinds of things that
you're very specific very elite group of
potential clients are interested in then
you've run targeted campaigns just
towards them and find them through
Facebook yeah and we start to really
kind of dive into a lot of that as well
here at Aweber just with a lot of the
Facebook retargeting it's really crazy
kind of what you can the info you can
capture about just you know one web
visitor that visited your page and that
sort of thing and you know obviously we
target them and you talked about landing
pages and all that good stuff which ties
in cool Scott is ready into say how do i
market my products to sell directly to
the end user who is currently buying
imported through distribution
he sells molded rubber safety products
he's cold calling he wants clients to
him instead of me trying to go out and
find them and he's trying to sell larger
ticket items so try to sell larger
ticket items to businesses who are
currently importing thereby through
distribution
how does he reach out to these guys and
sell these higher ticket items instead
of doing cold calling yeah I mean it's
uh it's a big question to handle but I
like kind of going back to what you said
of tapping into you know obviously
because he doesn't want to be hammering
with cold calls and you could land a
couple deals that way and get some
traction but who else in his space is an
influencer or he can kind of look to as
a mentor maybe not on the highest of
levels but somewhere in between they
could kind of carve out a path to kind
of help him get to where he needs to be
in terms of distribution in terms of
eyeballs right so you talked about
jumping into others other affiliates or
networks that have influence outside of
just yourself because you only get so
far with all your own internal efforts
but I would look for someone else
directly close to you know generally
made geographically close within his
face that could really help him kind of
dive into various strategies in the
distribution space obviously I can't dig
too far into that because that's really
not that's not my expertise but it's it
kind of the same principle pot of
applies that you just laid out of you
know finding others with had to have a
similar problem the same problem you can
kind of latch on to for expertise and
and dig in more there yeah I think
they're the the referral kind of
strategy is great here look at
influencers looking at people who
already selling to your target audience
not can you partner up with them
I'd also look at the authority strategy
on this one to think about what what
message you could add to be the
recognized authority on this industry
you know could you be speaking at
industry events
could you be writing columns in industry
magazines and journals could you be
creating content of its YouTube videos
or a blog or by the media in your
industry to talk about not just your
products that you're selling but the
industry as a whole and provide value to
your
customers so that they know you like you
trust you you want to learn more about
what you're doing right even just like
we're doing now we're talking about you
know we've got Patrick here from Aweber
with time your honor keys to help you
grow your business you know email is a
part of that but we're not here like
pimping out Aweber you got to go buy a
wherever now but I'm not at all yeah but
like providing content and being a
thought leader being an expert attracts
people to you they want to work with you
they want to learn about you so I think
those strategies would work really well
for Scott that plus what Patrick was
talking about finding your throw
partners right and that you know that
influencer so whether it's industry
related events content that you're
commenting on to kind of be a source for
others to converse with and then you
know again conversations that leads to
you know sales if we're if we're going
direct to the point and that's you know
everybody loves to buy everybody hates
being sold I mean you walk into you know
go to the mall and you go to a clothing
store and you get that weird feeling
because someone comes right up to you
and says hi can I help you today and
they're going you know everyone hates
that family but you know once you feel
that you're being helped then it's it's
much easier and everybody loves to get
to that point they love it and in the
comments Allen is writing I hope they
connect with you guys after this live
YouTube video will find you guys so just
connecting with you want to guys with us
the other people in the chat so just
sharing your opinions being vocal having
a stance on something already even what
we're doing right now are already is
attracting people who want to find out
learn more about what we're doing yeah
cool next comes in from Victor what
frequencies do you recommend on sending
out emails yeah good question does come
up so there's not a cookie cutter black
and white answer to this one you know a
lot of the the analysis we do is kind of
dive into entrepreneurs you know
accounts kind of their current sending
history whether they're with Aweber or
someone else because it's really
dependent upon your business I can tell
you this is kind of going off some some
industry blogs that I subscribe to and
you know the HubSpot sales blogs or
email marketing all that stuff gurus
early in the morning it kind of makes
sense is the is it's between like six
and nine is is the most popular time for
opens right so if you're looking to just
kind of cushion that open rate you know
people are getting their coffee they're
on their phones they're taking the train
in that's when people are locked in on
those devices and that's when they're
kind of engaging in content but it
really depends upon your product and in
kind of what works for you so there's no
I can't just tell you the cookie cutter
way but I can tell you know morning
makes sense and that's what we see a lot
but we do dive into a lot of you know
companies kind of set up to see what
really works for them because it's it's
not always just cut and dry yeah and I
think that the quality is much more
important in the quantity and not to get
too bent out of shape on how often
you're sending emails out more that the
emails that you are send you know are
really important valuable relevant for
your audience on my channel sorry my son
my my account I'll send out two emails a
week one will be part of an
autoresponder sequence that will usually
share the top video from my youtube
channel and another one will be a value
add content or something that I'm
promoting like this event here today
went out to my newsletter but I wouldn't
get too caught up like you have to email
your audience once a week or you're
gonna lose them because if you start
doing that and you're just mailing it in
and you're not sending good stuff
they're not gonna see your email you
want it to be that if you stop sending
emails people would write in to say hey
I didn't get your email what happened am
I still on the list which is half to me
a few times when I went on vacation I
didn't send an email people would write
his head didn't get your email what
happened is your newsletter canceled am
I still on it which is the same thing
for any of your marketing not just email
campaigns but look at my youtube channel
I do three video
a day on the channel and some people
think that that's crazy and it's too
much but it's three quality videos right
if you can create ideally you create
your mixing quality plus the quantity
but I get to pick one I'd go for quality
every day of the week so if you can only
budget in your time to write one quality
newsletter per month then do one per
month it's that's way better than
putting it in for just okay emails once
a week yeah and I was just gonna just
add to that with it's just all about
setting the expectations I mean if if
you're starting a blog or if you haven't
established blog or a business and you
have X amount already on your email list
and you're sending out content whether
it's daily weekly monthly it's you know
always think about what your users are
thinking about right are they ex are
they getting what you kind of set out to
send them so managing the expectations
if you're gonna send them a weekly you
know digest or you know monthly
newsletter then that's exactly what they
should get if there's if you're gonna be
sending them more frequently then you
know present those options kind of
before you go down that path so there's
a variety of ways you can do this in the
email world whether it's on the signup
form process where your users can kind
of select or you know deselect where and
when they get email so and then kind of
goes back to invite and feedback you
know just this is the the most powerful
channel of people raising their hands
that want info about you that want your
products and it's across all other
channels and you know I'll do and we do
webinars and kind of talk about this
it's crazy how powerful build your email
list is but again it's always remember
and invite feedback kind of that they're
there to and and make sure that you're
kind of on the ball in terms of those
expectations and you're not just kind of
going off on your end of the strategy
and just blast them out you know emails
at whatever given time make sure there's
a behind it so next one was Scott I have
a nail salon all I have is word of mouth
right now what should I do to start
marketing well good question Scott so
word of mouth is is awesome you have
that right out of the gate
I can tell you kind of where Aweber came
from we've been around about 17 years
and that's exactly how we grow
word-of-mouth of people enjoying the
product seen value in the product
passing along to their friends and other
business owners so that's great great
start
but it's I would say you know obviously
they're I would assume there's some sort
of a web presence there's a Facebook
page so make it you know what or you
know people are coming into your salon
so provide options for them to join up
to receive updates or promotions or kind
of coupons from your business so start
growing that list it's very important to
start now and that's gonna that's gonna
prove and turn into ROI for you in terms
of actual dollars so there's a lot of
cool things you can do and you know a
brick-and-mortar store you're you're
having people come into your salon you
can have people sign up to your email
list in house you know when they're
coming in and that sort of thing so a
lot of cool ways but build that list and
and start adding into that word-of-mouth
growth which is awesome yeah I wouldn't
discount word-of-mouth like you say all
I had was word of mouth right now that's
that's super powerful that's amazing if
you get word of mouth happening you know
a company is kill for that so you're
doing something right like you're
providing an amazing service you want to
be more than just giving somebody their
nail job right something that is so
remarkable that you want people to talk
about you so that's already a fantastic
start a nail salon is is local it's a
local business so you know I don't know
where you are but I probably wouldn't
come to you I'm not that I go to nail
salons but just in general because I'm
from Toronto
so what I would look at is heavy on the
local SEO and one of the things that we
do at our local I want a local dance
school business here teaching salsa in
Toronto when people have a really good
experience at the school we'll ask them
to go to Google our local profile page
and leave a review and so if you have
some people who are really loving what
you're all about you can have them go
and leave a review for you on Google and
that really helps you with your local
results so if somebody's searching nail
salon and you have
the amazing reviews from people who had
a great experience with you then you're
going to show up at the top of the
search engines all the time is super
helpful and effective strategy for a
local business as much if you have a fan
base right if you're getting
word-of-mouth and people love you then
it should be easy for them to want to
take that one extra step to help you out
yeah it's a great it's a great point
cool
next up Allen I'm starting a fruit
delivery business my market is
specifically the people living in condo
complexes in my place what's the best
way to get to them thank you from Allen
yes so the first thing that comes to my
mind is if he's living in a condo he's
not he necessarily doesn't have access
to all these names because I'm thinking
in the email world kind of maybe there's
a newsletter you can send out he's not
the owner of the complex correct or is
he just living in the complex just one
aha yeah I think the business is the
fruit delivery business not owning the
condos yeah so you know obviously
startup stage you know email might not
come come into play right out of the
gate you know whatever the venue is and
kind of the format of him setting up the
initial business whether it's you know
kind of you know street it's the fruit
delivery business is first my first move
would be kind of local minimalistic ads
like you're saying you know people want
to hear about this wherever they kind of
tap into so you know maybe maybe on
Facebook but maybe just the general you
know local you know advertisements out
of the gate maybe it's not the Yellow
Pages but trying to think through I mean
it's a local fruit delivery there's
there's a lot of things you can do I
mean I don't think email of us would
come out come out right away but what
are your thoughts on on the initial the
push there for local business like that
small local business yeah I think I
think is a combination and Allen is
saying it's a she says the she not a he
so sorry about that allergies yeah I
think Facebook could be a great way to
go if you could target people who live
in condos
I don't know if you can specifically do
that it's interesting to see what I
would try to do is I would try to have
it as a selling feature for the condos
if there's a way to work with the the
management to have it be have you be a
preferred seller there and some kind of
bonus feature for them to really give
and recommend to their to their client
base if you could give me preferred rate
to people who are at certain condos it
might be something that they could use
as a package to help promote their
condos when they're selling it now I was
looking at a condo and I want to get an
electric car and no condos have electric
vehicle plugs so like I can't
I either pick I left your vehicle or I
pick the condo and and it's such a
competitive industry to be in in the in
the condo market right now that this
could be a cool marketing way for them
to stand out so you know if they gave
away the first delivery for free or
something something that they could
offer as an enticement for people to
want to buy their condos that could be a
cool way to reach a lot of condo unit
owners yeah really quickly the
newsletter could still tie in you know
part of it could be education - like
what kind of food you're giving why is
it so important is it natural is it
organic is it local you know what the
health benefits can give me recipes all
that stuff could be massively helpful I
think in terms of making that first
entry I would try to work through the
condo owners the builders and see what
you might be able to get done there yeah
I'm sure they have so now you got my
wheels turn so I'm sure there's delivery
aspect so you're right I mean they
they're probably you know we even work
with and we power you know apartment
hire corporate entities that own various
you know housing department so there's
newsletters involved there so if you tap
into them as a local you know any new
residents coming in they have exclusive
promotions you know maybe through
Allen's her floor you know fruit
delivery business very similar to a lot
of the conversations we get into for
partnerships we're tapping in
we're trying to become an exclusive or
preferred provider in the email space
for you know various crms or other
online softwares which may produce some
marketing services like email so it's
it's kind of the same tactic where you
know let's let's jump into the higher
level entity on the corporate set on the
condo side and see if we can kind of do
the same thing with like a local
services as a fruit delivery business
our cool
much is writing in about emails what
emails have had the best response for
you are there any one or two that stand
out yeah so a good question so recent
split tests we did was was just all
around video and we know how crazy video
is and how it increases engagement so I
like to bring this example up because it
was so powerful so we did a simple test
so we sent out an email newsletter you
know to to newsletters one with video
and then one without and just to kind of
see the engagement terms of the open
rates and the clicks all those
engagement metrics and you know we we
doubled Plus on the one with video in it
now not to say that every time and you
must use you know video and every piece
of content you send out but it was
speaking to a community that was you
know it was a round video and it was had
a little bit of text in it and there was
one one without and one with and it was
just you know exceptional the engagement
we see in terms of the increase that
that's one I it always comes mine was
that it was that just like embedding a
YouTube video or a link to a video or
how did the video work so how ours works
is you embed the YouTube URL or a Vimeo
URL typically it links to your you know
it would like if we send email with Evan
Carmichael video it would link to your
YouTube page but it was you know it was
we just wanted to kind of see what what
really kind of was performing better and
by for that you know the one that had
the video was the engagement just
skyrocketed that's interesting so you
can
so when I do beat it now I'm curious for
me when I when I put videos out I'll
take the thumbnail and then I'll link
that just as an image so it's an image
that then links to my YouTube channel is
that the recommended way to do it or can
you embed a video or how did you guys do
it I'm just curious my own selfish yeah
you could certainly do that as well so
you can link any image to a specific URL
to a specific you know external you know
site but you might want to try out you
know dragging and dropping in the whole
the YouTube video so when the user gets
it they see the play button it's not
just an image and then once they click
on it it goes to your YouTube channel so
it's a little bit different than just
being an image externally in a way it
operates the same way but there's the
full YouTube video in there with the
play button and you might want to do a
test yourself see how that how that
works out I'm going to that's good I'm
getting the value on this too I love it
um much to your question let me loaded
again was what emails have the best
response for you I think a lot of it
just comes down to general general
marketing you know like the any titles
titles make a huge difference right if
you're asking a question if you're
saying something impactful if you're
using like the seven ways try to include
numbers all those all the stuff that
works in general
copywriting when we're promoting this
video or you know you're creating a
newsletter or you're you know taking out
an ad you know that headline makes a
huge difference and put in love and
spending some time to make sure that the
headline you know sings makes a big
impact and I think the easy way to do it
is to do split test so patrick talked
about a little bit before but one of the
things that's great about a weber is you
can when you're sending out a broadcast
email you can split test I don't know
how many times you can do it but you can
create multiple tasks and say you have
four versions or ten versions and you
can see which one has the best result
and so something I'm going to do it for
my book as an example you know
come with the title for my book I have a
working title but I'm going to be
looking at no variations to see what
what pulls the best using my Aweber list
to send out you know 10 different
versions with a subject line and
whatever yeah whatever it pulls the best
that's going to be the turn of the book
yeah and so the task to get to get the
best results for all your campaigns so I
find it super helpful you can't do that
on YouTube or another marketing but you
came with your email newsletter list I
find it super helpful yeah I mean cuz
you know so much more functionality just
taught in the email world cuz you own
that email list right so you're gonna
hook into a software be you own that
list and you know most popular probably
a split tested is the subject line is
right that's the first thing anyone sees
when you're on your iPhone or and we've
all you know deleted a ton tons of
emails that are unwanted but there's
always the ones that we save and we mark
them as important but like subject lines
and then you can get you know I just
mentioned video or just the way you kind
of maybe if it's a simple subject line
it's a video and then there's a line or
two of text you can even mess it you
know mess around with that liner to a
text you can really split test anything
but obviously the you know the subject
lines are huge that's that's that's
what's gonna pull in the click right
well Allen who had the fruit delivery
business wrote in to say wow thanks for
that so much value what you guys said it
definitely got ideas to work on so it's
good it's awesome and Tamara is ready to
follow up on that question or that topic
you mentioned about embedding the video
she writes can you do the image on the
embedded link to could this catch two
kinds of people the ones who clicked the
link and the ones that click the image
so she's trying to and I'm just
picturing this on the body of the email
she's looking to embed just pulling a
link or so for the Kindle ink be an
image to like that that embedded I think
it is like it is an image right like the
video inside the email there's a
thumbnail on it to its apps it's the
play button is it's an image of correct
and yes and you set what that image is
or just pulls their default from YouTube
it's gonna pull the default one the way
we work from YouTube that's a good
question that's actually in the roadmap
a lot of these little things that come
up so really good question in terms of
you know initially yeah pulls in the
YouTube thumbnail but you know clients
it does come up and so it's it's on the
roadmap our developers her heads down on
a lot of stuff but in terms of
manipulating that image other than just
the standard YouTube thumbnail it is
some ways we've talked about cool Wow I
mean you spending time on your YouTube
thumbnail and make that appealing for
people to click on so I would just drag
the YouTube video into the Aweber
newsletter template and it will auto
auto populate it for me
mm-hmm cool yeah I'm gonna test it I'm
gonna test it okay and then you the
image you can just if you just want if
you'd like the image better and you
don't want to pull in the the you know
the youtube link like you said you can
link that image like I believe that the
last question was over to a certain
video Richard is writing in creating
content can be difficult when working
full-time should I create a series of
emails with the help of a text writer or
drop new opt-ins into my monthly
newsletter should I create a series of
emails with the help of a writer or drop
a new opt-ins into my monthly newsletter
so I think to two questions going on so
just talking about creating content
right so we understand that you know
business owners are on the go and
entrepreneurs they want to they don't
necessarily always want to be crafting
and writing their content we're doing a
couple cool things on our end to kind of
curate content and just give
entrepreneurs and business owners the
ability you know pull in various
articles and content in their industry
or its relative to their audience and
then kind of post them some comments on
it and then blast it out so that's
actually a new cool app that were pay
attention for its called curate which
will be doing exactly that so in terms
of crafting the emails you know the way
we work a lot of the entrepreneurs or
clients are you know physically crafting
these emails so it's kind of really up
to you based on
if you feel you need you know
third-party source to kind of help you
right I mean there's plenty of companies
and services out there that do that so
on the content side I don't know what's
your experience with with that working
with tools to kind of craft content on
the go
how does it work out for you
so for me I'm particular with my content
I've had a hard time working with with
writers to get the words out of me and
save my voice I think that's the biggest
thing is when I when I send out a
newsletter or when I tweet or when I
leave comments if something's coming
from me I want it to be in my voice I
may be too anal about that maybe I care
too much about that and maybe maybe
maybe I forget that some Richard doesn't
care as much about it what you might do
is think about if you're not a strong
writer are you better at making videos
or you like it like recording something
down and giving that to somebody to to
type up I think the most important thing
in in sending out a newsletter or
creating content is that it's authentic
and the danger of just hiring someone to
do it is you know you don't wanna just
give somebody a topic and say hey write
write an article for me about five ways
to you know grow healthy fruits or
something you know it's not just about
regular content you want to have your
voice your opinion somewhere in there so
if you're using somebody to help you
create the content then just make sure
that your voice is still there it's
authentic it's the the tone even if the
exact words aren't what you would say
the tone and the the the context is like
represents what you stand for no so that
would be my advice yeah I mean if rich
feels comfortable with someone who kind
of can replicate or kind of you know you
know with you know holding the
credibility of his voice you're right I
mean it really depends and then there I
there's a second question too on opt-ins
not sure exactly he was talking about
working with often
on his email list right I will he poses
in either or should I create a series of
emails with the help of writer or drop
new opt-ins
into a monthly newsletter so drop I'm so
dropping new opt-ins into a monthly
newsletter I'm thinking of like email
addresses and contacts which you would
be sending your newsletter to so it's
kind of two different it's growing the
audience of email addresses and contacts
and then it's creating the content so
it's kind of I'm not a hundred percent
sure exactly how to tie that in I mean
it's obviously hopefully he's doing both
and he's and he's killing it doing both
you know building his own internal email
list of followers and then you know he
could that was good advice I'm figuring
out the best way to go about creating
contact yeah I've had to pick between
adding people to my newsletter or
creating quality content I would go with
the content because if you're just
adding people into your list without
having anything to give them that's the
quality they're gonna balance anyway he
wrote back to say question answers thank
you so we answer this question thank you
thank you for asking Richard okay next
up Derek question I'm involved with a
start-up brand of clothing as a start-up
what are some effective methods of
marketing specifically for my industry I
want to be very mindful over my budget
as unhealthy spending can be detrimental
to the life of my business
so marketing a startup clothing brand
yeah
very cool and wish you the best of
success I have a buddy that it's kind of
doing the same thing well he's been at
it for about ten years but very cool
yeah so in terms of marketing in the
email world of any startup you know
regardless of clothing line or you know
a fruit fruit business um its we have a
lot of clients that kind of use you know
free aversions to kind of be cost to be
mindful of the cost so a lot of them you
know they're looking at MailChimp for
you know that freemium version but I
also do work with a lot of startups that
you know we're reaching a point of kind
of being serious about growing their
audience and all different channels and
one of those channels being
so they're willing to jump into beyond
those 2000 contacts where MailChimp
provides free and and you know solution
like us where we're only nineteen
dollars a month it makes sense because
we don't have that freemium version but
again kind of just the general marketing
influencers who are in you know mentors
in the clothing clothing industry
there's there's a ton of trade shows I
know there's one crazy new clothing line
trade show in Vegas where my buddy goes
to and he's he's kind of you know he's
been in this thing for ten years but he
so operates under the startup mentality
bailey say a big brand is you know
there's no overnight success overnight
success take ten to fifteen years right
so it's you know Damon Daymond John of
Shark Tank will tell you that
FUBU wasn't an overnight success it was
took him years to do but you know on the
marketing side tap in tap into trade
shows and you know just growing your
audience and there's a blog where you're
talking about things in the industry if
you're talking about fashion you know
build your audience there everyone's
queuing in online and that just converts
to clicks and sales of your t-shirts of
your you know your apparel and all that
stuff yeah I definitely look at
influencers I think that's the way to go
with clothing I would try to look at the
top youtubers and instagramers that you
like and reach out to them and see if
they'd be willing to take a look at your
clothing I've worn some shirts from
people who sent them in to me that I
liked and then I get asked questions you
know where did you get that shirt and
we'll leave the link in the description
of the video and people go and buy them
they got nothing coming in where this
guy made this awesome bull and I'm a
tourist and so he's gonna send me this
bull shirt and I'm gonna wear it in some
of my videos I'm sure it's gonna help
him with his sales so you want people
who have an audience to wear it and
share it now they have to like it
you know the ball is a little weird for
me but most of the stuff that I wear
would be entrepreneur related I'm not
wearing my own stuff it's something else
that we're into entrepreneurship so I
would start with thinking about who
youtubers that you already follow who
are the people Instagram or Twitter or
bloggers that you already follow and
like and enjoy their stuff because when
you reach out you have an authentic
message and hopefully they recognize you
because you've been leaving comments on
their channels already much easier than
doing a cold email out to somebody who
you don't really know and saying this is
great for your audience so I think the
influencer marketing is death for the
wait doesn't mean it's a lot of hustle
it's time this has to cost you anything
in terms of dollars apart from sending a
shirt sample off to dump it in the mail
yeah I mean while you're working on all
the other daily you know the daily grind
stuff that you do like you said it
doesn't happen overnight but influencers
with like especially looking at a
clothing brand someone that has some
notoriety is it seen wearing that you
know we've we've all kind of seen those
stories that's huge so keep shooting for
that for that kind of big big I guess
big jump to the next level big piece of
like hey you know it was seen on TV or
something like that Wow Daymond John and
FUBU and his launch is with LL Cool J
who agreed to wear his shirt are you
sure they're his hat I figured what it
was on a commercial and that helped kind
of skyrocket the business because ll who
was the big rapper at the time agreed to
wear it and Daymond basically camped out
on LL lon
I kept harassing him until he got a yes
out of it but yeah it's such an easy way
to do it easy in terms of the strategies
easy the execution requires a lot of
time and effort cool Jane is asking
about how to brand yourself in the
entertainment industry how can you
create a brand for yourself in the
entertainment industry
so I'm not a brand in the entertainment
industry but I tell you the first thing
I would do is you know what ever heard
her her kind of thing is and whether
they she's an actress or comedian to me
it starts on line with you know whether
your content right you need to jump into
the
fools of the youtubes of the world you
know you know more than anyone about
this right growing your audience there
and video and content and getting in
front of eyeballs so in the
entertainment industry you want to be
online right cuz and that's where you're
gonna get seen him not sure if she what
she does that he Debbie called uh to see
what Jane is it correct yeah not sure
what you do Jane but I'm sure there's
some sort of you have some sort of
online presence as it is but get
yourself out there we talked about
influencers it's very important as well
but just your content if it's video
related just just keep pushing content
content content I was I used to work
with a lot of web publishers and a few
startups up in New York City some of
them that were that went on to create
huge audiences and get acquired and the
number one thing they did was just push
push push content every day and stay
true to that it wasn't easy
out of the gate but you know those are
the ones who kind of really take it to
the next level in terms of getting mass
eyeballs and just building an audience
you know that's huge
yeah I agree III think it's a matter of
figuring how you unique I think there's
a lot of copycats in the entertainment
industry and the ones who stand out are
the ones who unique so it starts with
what is what's so special about you
what's your message how is it different
what do you stand for as an artist as an
entertainer and then how do you express
that in a way that's different than
other people I remember watching a video
clip of fifty says talking about people
who are submitting demo albums to him
and he said I heard ten people last week
who sound like Lil Wayne and they
sounded exactly like Lil Wayne and he
said that's great you sound exactly like
little Wayne but there's already little
Wayne so why am I gonna go with you
right and so it's not not just trying to
emulate and sound like somebody else was
hot right now
but finding your own voice that's unique
and different that people will remember
so that they'll say well they sound
likes you they sound like Jane and not
like somebody else I think it's super
important I think easy way to stars if
you are if you're a singer I love it
when singers do covers of other songs
let's twist it to make it their own
version you know so if you're like a
heavy metal rocker or a rapper you know
take a Justin Bieber song and make it
your own
write those things like they do or don't
do a cover of another rapper or another
heavy metal star take something out of a
genre and put it in your own style and
that helps attract an audience for your
your original songs as well but you need
to have that unique voice that unique
style that people can say that is that
person that is Jean and why she's
special and into so going off that so
you mentioned Justin Bieber earlier so I
was tuning in with the wife to American
Idol here in the States and it's in its
last season but it speaks true to what
you said because you know awesome
singers are down like the top 10 and you
know this this I think it was a female
girl who did a cover of a Justin Bieber
song and you know there's others who
kind of did similar stuff and they
knocked it out of the park great voices
tons of talent but all the judges and
kind of you know what I was hanging out
with my wife I was like you know what
was really good about that
it was a Justin Bieber song which she
changed it and completely made it almost
new and like the audience picks up on
that the judges kind of spoke to that
and that's what you know gave her that's
so true though I mean it's a dime a
dozen but if you can make you your own
it's a home run yeah they'll try to be
the next text whoever in your industry
try to be the first of you and that's
that's applicable to not just
entertainment but any entrepreneur
Victor's writing then this day are you
guys going to have this live video on
for later review it's awesome it's
awesome information yeah so this video
is live for people we're tuning right
now but it'll live on my youtube channel
I don't know if it gets uploaded to the
Aweber channel as well or clips but it's
definitely the same length will be
available afterwards you can watch the
whole thing back
Scott wrote in the say I'm looking into
loyalty programs what do you think about
loyalty programs and do you have
opinions on which would be better so
loyal Pro Lowell T programs are
definitely good we don't we don't get
into a lot of that with with the email
space certainly something that could
just be one factor in building someone's
brand starting out or or established and
then that taps into a whole influencer
world as well new conversations start
from kind of building your own loyalty
program so I can't really I would like
to is there specific business use case
that she or he has in terms of the
product I'd be curious to know where
this yeah stop if you want to if you
want to right back up to what kind of
company you are launching and how you
want to use a little T program that
could provide more context I think I
think both the programs are great it
just it's a lot of work to set up and to
do it well and is that there are some
easy ones like if you had the nail salon
that we talked about before you know you
have you have your punch card and every
you know nine times you come you get the
tenth one for free those are some easier
things to do I guess it just I just
caution against try to think too much
trying to make things too complicated a
lot of entrepreneurs and this was me too
in my first business like I had the
greatest plan in the world but I would
spend three months working on the plane
and then it was too difficult to execute
again so I didn't have the customers to
justify it and so sometimes it's easy to
get lost in complex planning as opposed
to actually do the things that help grow
your business so lovely programs are one
of those things that can work just
agnostic don't make it too complicated
and again if you want to provide more
context so Patrick and I can give you
some better advice on the kind of
interfere in that'd be awesome yeah I'm
a part of I'm a part of a bunch of them
locally just kind of
yeah local like you said nail salon or
frozen-yogurt do we go to so we got the
the hole punches so definitely good from
a small business perspective but I would
agree you know you're starting something
now and it's like before you do you know
just do something like get started with
it instead of worrying about you know a
large eccentric loyalty program that may
fit in and may come into play down the
road cool
Edwin writing in I'm a designer trying
to start a creative agency as a start-up
water some methods of marketing for my
creative services do I need to find my
clients or let them try to go find me so
with designer trying to start a creative
in the creative agency so I would just
so obviously he's a designer he's has
some experience he he has a portfolio
right maybe he's a web designer or maybe
he's good with WordPress so who is he
worked with who's like if I'm in your
shoes I'm saying who have I worked with
that I have a pretty decent relationship
that I can reach out to and just have a
conversation with and you know see if
there may be an opportunity there so
kind of looking internally at your own
experience of your own network that you
can tap into you know whether it's just
you starting out as a freelancer as a
consultant which you know we have a lot
of those that use Aweber and their
marketing consultants and so they work
with a bunch of clients but look at your
own Network who do you know who may they
you know who may someone that you know
no it's it's like you said the
influencer is a market just having a
conversation with work you've already
done and I know that you know the web
design of design in general is so valued
you know today in terms of being able to
be a web designer and you know how to
code and work with HTML or just maybe
it's visual design it's such a valuable
asset to have that people really value
that and then I'm a I'm guessing that
you know one or two people that you
could you know almost look at his
clients out of the gate to get you
really start yeah I think for this kind
of business I mean heavily looking at
referrals and alliances I don't know
what part of the
the design you're doing like you'd be
doing web design or graphic design or
all of that but you can look at
companies for building websites you can
look at companies are doing SEO services
you can look at companies that provide a
video production again the your your a
piece in a bigger wheel of services that
are being sold when somebody is doing
marketing or branding so you're a part
of that but you can connect with the
copywriters and the other designers and
the video guys because they're also into
the same market and they offer you can
use you to help bolster themselves like
it's if they can go in it can be hard
for somebody who just does writing to go
in and get the client but if they also
have someone help design around the
content that they're creating that's
that's a ways that's a bonus and so I
would be spending as much time as
possible trying to make local
connections with people who have
complementary businesses to mine to be
able to go in as a team to these pitches
because it adds value for them through
their clients as well I think it's in
this kind of business is the easiest way
to get started if you can fill it up
with fill network up for you but
potentially your first client could be
another agency which like you mentioned
isn't it's so heavy on whatever part of
web design they're getting into so you
know maybe you're a 1099 initial
contractor but that's that agency who's
kind of handles the broader scope of
things beneath some design help boom you
got one client right there and then you
know kind of just snowballs from there
whether you're working with agencies or
someone else that just may need help on
the design area so you know it's a it's
a great place to start because a lot of
agencies will outsource the the rates
are lower because they have to make a
profit off of what you're selling but it
helps you get your feet wet in the
industry helps improve your skills and
helps you build up a portfolio so yeah I
love that point John is writing in how
can you present yourself as unique when
I have a lot of people thinking that all
magicians are the same
or interchangeable so I guess he's a
magician how can he be neat The
Magicians reduces entrepreneurs fears oh
that's awesome we have I actually work
with a few that I've on-boarded here
clients have aweber that are magicians
so they're producing content all the
time they're sending out that newsletter
they have a YouTube channel they're
showing off their street magic or there
you know in venue magic if this one guy
he was just going around to a local
restaurant they hired him so like it was
a kind of an informal setup so he would
he would do his little tricks and card
tricks for people while they were
waiting for their food but yeah and it's
it's just getting content out there and
kind of separating yourself so there's
other similar tricks that you're seeing
others or people you aspire to be like
do like try to figure out a new twist to
it kind of like you mentioned how
entertaining on you I mean if I'm
looking at a magician and you know it's
not everybody's David Copperfield but
you know how engaging like with the
audience are there and just as a they're
kind of delivery you know I love
magicians
got my wheels turn I'm just thinking
yeah I had to fix them when I was little
with the you know you disappear the
handkerchief and then that was about it
yeah I agree so so first is were you
thinking about the tricks themselves and
you make something different special you
need never you that might be hard I
think I think the challenge is that a
lot of people think oh it's gonna be the
same stuff and so it's on YouTube is not
the same stuff does that hiring a
magician if I think every magician is
the same then I'm just gonna be down on
price somehow when you come out to my
event why would I pay double for you
you've heard of that guy who does the
same trick so it's one showing me that
moves that you have the tricks that you
have are differently uniquely put your
own spin on it I think Tim is bringing
one yourself to the show because it's
not just it was the tricks it's also
about how you presented him so David
Copperfield is himself and he has
a certain way of delivering his tricks
and demon Blaine you know has a totally
different style of how he does his thing
so what's your style just like we talk a
little Wayne before don't try to be a
cheap man's version of David Copperfield
be the best version of yourself and at
the end of the day what people want is
the reactions like I want to see your
chicken be wowed and be entertained and
feel happy and be curious about how did
you pull that off and so it's a very
visual medium and I agree with Patrick
about getting videos up on YouTube
not just of what you're doing but the
reaction of the crowd to see the show
that you can put on and then you can
follow that up with an email sequence
people to get on your list to get a
monthly you know new show of what you're
doing but I think it's on you to really
again not just emulate these other guys
even in what you're saying here in your
question it wasn't I didn't see anything
that's uniquely different about you John
Hope the magician so both of those
things different different tricks
different moves and also how you present
them with the entertainment value
whether are you joking and having fun
and laughing and doing gags with the
audience are you very serious in this
degree 'since people are really curious
you know something that fits into the
persona but it kind of who you are bring
more of yourself to it that's how you
start to being different
yeah it's building a personal brand like
you know Criss Angel Mindfreak
right that's kind of his thing you have
David Blaine who I love it's kind of
that you know delivery and then there's
so it's really about building the brand
and just being like you said personality
and then the back half of that is
actually the tricks you know and that's
how we're all fooled anyway because
we're paying attention to someone's
delivery and before we know that they
took our wallet you know right so that's
part of the show and entertainment value
yeah I love it
patrick already bumping up against the
clock here for people who want to learn
more about you if they were the
questions I have your Twitter account up
in
in the title so they can find it there
but how can I learn about you and more
about Aweber and what you're all about
yeah absolutely so any questions guys
like come up pertain to your business
anything at all if you guys are startup
if you're an established company who has
an email list or is looking to you know
build on that or as it pertains to other
channels not just email because you know
I have experience the last ten years
kind of working with entrepreneurs
working with business owners just
building their digital audience so
whether it's paid ads or display or
Facebook or email like I kind of got
into email to really be focused and
targeted moving back home here and
getting engaged and getting married
that's it was great great opportunity
here today weber but it's such a
powerful way to it's the most direct way
in terms of you building your brand and
you ultimately selling to your community
so hit me up on twitter at pete Tut's
with a Z and my you know I don't know if
my email is up there Patrick EDA Weber
comm shoot me a note happy to see how we
can help and be an asset to you guys
cool and to learn about Aweber just a
weber comm yeah Aweber comm go to Aweber
comm any specific questions around the
platform itself we do have a 30 day
trial you know for all clients to kind
of kick the tires and see how how we can
be a fit for you guys let's go to Aweber
calm and any questions reach out to me
directly
awesome well Patrick thank you so much
for the time thank you guys for watching
live and we'll see you on a future
episode yeah thanks guys from wherever
you guys to didn't from today we're
outside Philly here and in Chalfont
Pennsylvania it's been great really
appreciate it thanks a lot love it